hello guys i'm ryan right I am Jerry so
if you saw Tyrone Magnus's video about
him being on netflix now through the
company r if this is the same exact
video but us talking right now it's the
same exact estimate if you really don't
want to watch this and you just want to
go to Tyrell Magnus's do that but I'll
give you a quick breakdown hey Jerry can
you ask me what is rich hey what's riff
ryan right well riff enables fans to
create and watch video comment area that
can be viewed side by side with TV shows
and movies is that is that so that is so
hey how do frequently asked questions he
asked questions yeah till hey uh why are
people watching others watch TV Ryan I
honestly don't know this is the question
we've been trying to figure out since we
started riff allows us to experience our
favorite TV shows and movies with others
it turns streaming video into a shared
experience that's deeply familiar
watching TV with friends I earn my
website slipper watch TV with a friend I
don't think uh how do I become a creator
Ryan cheer me sure Jerry Jerry Jerry you
can sign up to be a creator on this page
and I'm looking at right now they will
be in touch with you via email soon
after with instructions just go to their
website rifts TV / about and there's a
click here button but Ryan I mean what
do you need must need stuff what do you
need in order to watch a video on ref
you know well Jerry as you struggle to
make that sentence a more real by adding
a llama they make it sound very gonna
make it more fun interest okay okay okay
riffs browser extension it currently
works on the desktop version of Chrome
oh wow Google Chrome additionally in
order to view the commentary video side
by side with the TV show or movie if
yours must have a subscription in
netflix support for other streaming
services and browsers is coming soon
what if i don't have a netflix
subscription well you can sign up for
one
month free yet jackass at Netflix com
you know you should do he'll see fall
riff on facebook and twitter there's a
link in the description box for riff
yeah you can may you could win a netflix
gift card from their social media wait
Ryan I have another question and it's
not answered in the FA Hughes what
should I do well you can feel free to
email them at team at rift TV oh good
yeah if you guys didn't get the
breakdown we're basically you know you
can watch side-by-side with us as we
watch first when we do is masters of
nuttin yeah if you get like a really big
teeth master yeah if you get a really
big TV it almost feel like we're
actually there exactly exactly you get
the viewership expand oh you guys like
reactions then [ __ ] watch it there you
go now Tyrone read his email so I'm
gonna read our email which is
essentially the same email as Tyrone's
accept it says Ryan in there hi Ryan oh
it's you but long-awaited day is finally
here first off we rename meta cast to
riff WWF TV we felt in riff sounds like
a sex position to lead on time no really
felt that meta cast was too long and
didn't capture the fun of the product
we've stook the fast fast few months
building riff and I couldn't be more
excited to share the beta with you you
can find us the real rejects a trip TV /
the rejects if you like us to make any
changes to your profile please let me
know yes I have a dick pic I'm willing
to put up there if you wouldn't mind we
have a couple of favors to ask oh boy
please share your rift video with your
youtube subscribers BAM we recommend
posting the commentary portion of your
video to YouTube and linking to the full
oh you want me to do all that alright
and then you could work for it bro
please share a quick explanation or if
we took time to explain rift please
share your video on Twitter or Facebook
this has been posted on Twitter and
Facebook yeah please add riff as a link
on your youtube profile yes it is there
where I'm youtube profile gotcha please
ask your fans with TV shows and movies
they'd like you to watch you now have
the whole library of netflix to choose
from every
movie on Netflix yeah we ran every TV
show hey guys what do you want us to
review on Netflix yeah comment below and
tell us and we'll watch it together yeah
yeah even if we've already seen it hey I
mean you know you watch movies more than
once certain things you know yeah shows
a i mean i was watching kimmy schmidt
and like so many things come out the
second time I saw Star Wars once had
opinion started twice had different
opinions saw the third time had even
different her opinions there we go